pick up my reserves
uh i'm gonna go with the first timer
again lamellar ball
lamellar ball is spot opened up in the
on the eastern conference side because
he's a pleasure five minutes
that's must-see five come on lebron just
make him sweat it out just make him
sweat it out take anybody else
with this with the sixth pick
uh
in the second round
per request of the chuckster i'm going
with fred van fleet there you go there
you go first timer
first timer in history well katie i'm
gonna help katie out katie just needs
sides right now to me oh i think you
remember last time
lebron said he needed
yeah yeah
i'm gonna need some size for sure yeah i
need some size and um
interior yeah
especially with giannis and lebron james
without a question such great basketball
this year
i need somebody to offset that so i
agree with uh rudy gobert i agree i
agree
that worked out nicely it worked out
nicely i mean he can't let people run
through the lane
that's somebody defending back chestnut
checkers hey that's a hey when somebody
want out you let them go don't let them
come back i'm with you k.d that's how i
cut my hair off
so uh james harden goes to
uh
lebron james is the final selection
of the all-star draft
jack
is he can he is he is he he hasn't
played is he healthy who's that
james he hasn't played uh dude he's like
what happens if he doesn't he got traded
he's healthy now he's missed the last
three with a with a hammy
see and now we know why lebron carries a
clipboard with him to the uh to the left
oh my god right now he's rubbing some
ice and hot on that thing he's playing
the next game
those questions
okay
jd just
next year bring a clipboard that comes
in it comes in very handy yeah you have
to you can hide
we will come back and uh break down the
rosters the 2022. it's gonna be a good
all-star draft presented by nike